knapp vorbei Präsident Erdogan verpasst
die Wiederwahl am 28 Mai wird sich nun
entscheiden ob der alte türkische
Präsident auch der neue Präsident sein
wird
49,5% hatten für ihn gestimmt
44,9% für die Opposition auf dem
Kandidaten kemalige der Rollo mit seinem
großen Bündnis der Routen viele
Hoffnungen umso größer jetzt die
Enttäuschung auch bei einigen deutschen
Politikern die türkische Gemeinschaft
hier im Land hält aber mehrheitlich der
AKP die Treue Erdogan vor der Stichwahl
kein Machtwechsel in der Türkei unser
Thema heute in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin das sind meine Gäste Dennis you
cellis bei uns erst Korrespondent der
Welt wegen seiner journalistischen
Arbeit saß er ab Februar 2017 ein Jahr
lang ohne Anklage in Haft in der Türkei
Bülent Event begrüße ich ehemaliger
Vizepräsident der Union internationaler
Demokraten ehemalsd das ist eine
Lobby-Organisation der türkischen
Regierungspartei AKP in Europa und
insbesondere in Deutschland jetzt ist
der Politikberater Max lux ist bei uns
verbunden ist 90 die Grünen erst
Vorsitzende der Deutschen türkischen
Parlamentariergruppe und hat dem Auftrag
des Europarates die Wahl beobachtet er
war in der markier so heißt es das ist
im Südosten Gebiet Katharina Willinger
begrüße ich sie ist Leiterin des ARD
Studios in Istanbul von dort ist sie uns
zugeschaltet schönen guten Abend auch
Frau Willinger
wie enttäuscht sind sie von diesem
Ergebnis das ist eine Stichwahl gibt und
das nicht der Oppositionsführer auf den
sie gehofft hatten jetzt die Wahl
gewonnen hat
man sollte also Journalist sollte man ja
nicht allzu sehr unabhängig von eigenen
politischen Präferenzen
sollte man ja nicht mit mit dieser oder
jener Partei oder Kandidaten bei Wahlen
mitfiebern ich glaube die Situation in
der Türkei ist nur jetzt eine andere es
war keine Entscheidung zwischen wie in
Deutschland wie ein anderen
demokratischen Ländern zwischen dieser
Partei oder jener Partei diesen
Kandidaten oder jeden Kandidaten sondern
es war die Frage ob die Türkei die vor
allem in den letzten Jahren und der
Erdogan nach der Einführung dieses
sogenannten präsidentialsystems und
derart in jeder Hinsicht wirtschaftlich
was im Rechtsstaat Antrieb am betrifft
Grundfreiheiten und und und so
runtergerockt war dass sich eine
Opposition die sich auf der anderen
Seite über alle unter über viele
Unterschiede hinweg zusammengerauft hat
dass sie gewinnen würde um um die
Demokratie wieder herzustellen zusammen
die normal um einen vielleicht ein
besser noch als vorher aber ein zurück
zu Demokratie darum ging es nicht ob
diese oder jene Kandidat gewinnen würde
weswegen ich und auch die Umfragen waren
entsprechend weswegen ich in diesem
Sinne enttäuscht bin von dem enttäuscht
war vielmehr von diesem Ergebnis weil
seit heute gibt es ernstzunehmende
Hinweise dass das Ergebnis womöglich
doch nicht ganz so ausgefallen ist wie
am Sonntag in der Nacht verkündet
darüber können wir aber vielleicht
gleich im Anschluss reden gleich noch
mal rüber Frau Willinger der Favorit für
den 28 Mai heißt jetzt Erdogan er hat ja
dann doch die meisten Stimmen heißt das
Rennen ist gelaufen da gibt's noch
Chancen dass es doch zu einem
Machtwechsel kommen könnte
weil wir lassen jetzt mal das was Dennis
jüge gerade gesagt hat also die diese
Vorwürfe die Hinweise darauf dass da in
der Wahl manipuliert wurde außen vor und
ich beantworte Ihre Frage dahingehend
dass es zu Stichwahl kommt und diese
beiden Kandidaten ins Rennen gehen und
ja dann geht aus meiner Sicht Erdogan
als klarer Favorit ins Rennen nicht nur
weil er jetzt auf dem Papier einen
höheren Prozentsatz hat an stimmen
sondern auch weil er der Mann ist der
ein Großteil der Medien in der Hand hat
ich habe es immer wieder betont in den
vergangenen Tagen auch 95% der Medien in
der Türkei etwa gelten als regierungsnah
und natürlich hat er eine enorme
sendefläche das hat den Wahlkampf ja in
den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten auch
dominiert er kann als Staatspräsident
teure Wahl Geschenke machen das hat er
in den vergangenen Wochen auch immer
wieder gemacht es gab eine Absenkung des
Rentenalters es gab andere Wahl
Geschenke es gab diverse Einweihung von
Schnellzügen von Brücken von
drohnenträgern und das kommt natürlich
auch bei seiner Wählerschaft an auch bei
denen die vielleicht im Grunde über
vieles enttäuscht trotzdem kam das
scheinbar an und ich denke das wird auch
den Wahlkampf in den nächsten zehn elf
Tagen bis zur Stichwahl prägen was ist
das ist ein Punkt den Frau Willinger
sagt warum Erdogan so beliebt ist er
hatte ja den den abends Bonus den er da
voll ausgeführt hat trotzdem ist eine
hohe Inflation dem Land geht es
wirtschaftlich schlecht
hohe Arbeitslosigkeit auch bei jungen
Menschen hat das alles gar keine Rolle
gespielt also kaum ist
tatsächlich nicht so gut aber die Frau
Willingen gemacht hat er noch hat
Maßnahmen ergriffen indem er indem wir
die Folgen von der wirtschaftliche
gelindert hat und deshalb ist die
Wirtschaft jetzt nicht so weil es ja
nicht gewesen weil er seit zwei Jahren
mehrere Unterstützung für welche welche
Bürger organisiert hat aber wichtig ist
wir müssen wenn wir solche
Wahlergebnisse analysieren nicht nur von
der aktuellen Zustand ausgehen sondern
man muss auch die Soziologie der Türkei
betrachten also ich bin der Meinung also
ich habe Respekt nicht verloren ich habe
persönlich getroffen
aber aus meiner Sicht war einfach der
falsche Kandidat nicht nur weil der
charismatisch nicht gegen charismatisch
war und ich bin nicht vielleicht so
dominant wie Erdogan es ist sondern
er wird das wissen alle wie zu sein also
nichts gegeneinander
Türkei
Kurdistan Nachteil ich glaube an diese
Faktoren die soziologische Faktoren
haben auch eine Rolle gespielt
ja seit 21 Jahren gemacht er hat
Instrumente sich wieder wählen zu lassen
aber man muss auch sagen dass er
aufgrund der Medien
die er die unterstützen auch sich als
eine starke Führer immer
vorgeführt hat und die Türkei die Türken
sagen wir brauchen jemanden der hat
handlungsfähig ist der
durchsetzungsstark ist und so weiter und
diese Fähigkeiten hat er dann am Ende in
den letzten 20 Jahren gewesen Elo sie
haben jetzt diese Wahl beobachtet wurden
in Europa vom europarater zu entsandt
wir haben sie die Abstimmung erlebt es
gab ja jetzt auch schon angesprochen die
Diskussionen darüber wie demokratisch
war diese Wahl ist die Möglichkeit
gegeben dass da Sachen manipuliert
werden was wissen sie darüber
ja erstmal müssen wir glaube ich
festhalten dass dieser Wahlkampf ein
sehr unfairer Wahlkampf war das sieht
man zum Beispiel an einem
oppositionsverfahren gegen die
Opposition einen an einem
Verbotsverfahren gegen die
Oppositionspartei HDP das schon seit
Jahren läuft dann einem Politikverbot
für den Istanbul der Oberbürgermeister
immer nur das zum Glück noch nicht
rechtskräftig ist und den Medien
Katharina Willinger hat gerade gesagt in
der Hand von Erdogan sind und daher ist
dieser Wahlkampf in jedem Fall unfair
verlaufen wir haben von der Beobachter
Mission des Europarates z.B festgestellt
dass in 4% der Wahllokale wo wir
Stichproben genommen haben die Wahlurnen
nicht richtig versiegelt waren das kann
man auch unserem Bericht entnehmen und
das ist natürlich etwas was große
Fragezeichen bei uns aufwirft wir haben
insbesondere im kurdischen Südosten wo
ich unterwegs war und in den erzgebieten
Gebieten vermehrt war lokale als negativ
bewerten müssen von der Situation die
sich dort gezeigt hat wir hatten auch
einmal diese Situation in einem
Wahllokal in die Arbeit hier wo die die
hühnerpartie eine Hochburg hat also eine
Partei der kurdischen Hisbollah die mit
im Erdogan Lager ist wo wirklich die
Stimmung ein bisschen so wirkte als
würden sie die Leute dort ermüden wollen
ihre Stimme abzugeben und das sind
natürlich alles Dinge die große
Fragezeichen aufwerfen genauso wie die
Tatsache dass die Wahlbehörde nicht
wirklich kooperativ umgegangen ist mit
uns als internationalen Wahl
BeobachterInnen und Wahlbeobachter aber
die Wahlbeteiligung war ja extrem hoch
93 Prozent glaube ich ja jedenfall
wo sehen sie oder welche Quellen haben
sie die sagen dass da manipuliert wurde
darf ich vor noch einen anderen Punkt
ergänzend machen zu dem was Frau
wohliger und Helge wenn gesagt haben
Stichwort Medien macht zum Beispiel muss
man einen Punkt auszuführen das ist
nicht so wie man sich das in Deutschland
vielleicht vorstellt das halt einer auf
allen Kanälen alles voll quasi kann
Erdogan als der 2002 durfte war ja auch
mit einem Politikverbot belegt er dann
durfte ja persönlich damals gar nicht
kandidieren bei der bei dem ersten Mal
als Jappy angetreten ist die er dort und
die AKP hatten auch damals das gesamte
skeptischement hinter sich sie hatten
ein Fernsehsender auf ihre Seite war
Kanal 7 bin ich die richtige das war
damals nur Kanal 7 es gab keinen zweiten
und das waren zwei Zeitung trotzdem hat
Erdogan und wenn man die durch die
vielleicht noch so vor allem die nicht
ähm trotzdem hat er dort diese Wahl
gewonnen heute ist dieser Einsatz den
Medien macht ist einfach nicht alle
Kanal Kanäle voll zu quasseln sondern
ähm dann werden dann zum Beispiel
wahlvideos der Opposition geführt
angebliche wahlvideos
wo suggeriert wird das ist ein
Wahlwerbespot der GLP da sieht
stahlrollo mit Unterstützung von
pkk-anführern und das gefälscht
gefälscht und das geht über die Kanäle
das zeigen sie in Kundgebung das und das
ist eine so abgeschlossene Welt auch das
viele dieser Wähler das gar nicht mit
nichts anderes mitkriegen also die ist
es nicht nur
Medien Macht gegen den in der Türkei
früher erdogan hat der Aufstieg von
Erdogan war gegen auch gegen das mediale
estab geschmeckt aber solche Sachen man
hat ihm damals alles mögliche
vorgeworfen aber solche Sachen gab es
damals nicht und er hat natürlich viel
mehr Sendezeit sich nehmen können Frau
Willinger was wenn man das aber doch
weiß also ist es so ähm gibt's da nicht
nur eine Stimmung auch dass Menschen
sagen ja das ist ja das stimmt ja alles
nicht das ist ja gefälscht also wird da
im Land drüber gesprochen
wenn sie es nicht mitbekommen dann ist
das natürlich auch schwer das zu
hinterfragen denn die südtirol hat
natürlich ganz recht wenn diese
Wahlwerbespots da über eigentlich die
wahlkampfbühnen der AKP also der
erdogan-partei laufen die dann so
zusammengeschnitten sind als wären es
die richtigen dann schaltet
beispielsweise das öffentlich-rechtliche
Fernsehen oder die diversen Kanäle nicht
um wenn Sie diese Wahlkampfveranstaltung
übertragen sie senden sozusagen diesen
live Feed auch über ihre Eltern und das
ist natürlich höchst fraglich und das
kommt dann bei den Leuten an denn eben
ein Großteil der Menschen schaut eben
auch diese Mainstream-Medien es gibt nur
einen Bruchteil von Menschen die dann
die
oppositionellen oder die unabhängigen
Medien konsumieren die kriegen also gar
nicht mit und das wird dann natürlich
auch nicht hinterfragt also ich habe
mich auch natürlich in den Tagen vor der
Wahl in den Wochen vor der Wahl immer
wieder mit Regierungsanhängern
unterhalten mit den gesprochen und da
musste ich feststellen dass diese Art
von Privat nach wie vor extrem
tief greift und einfach tiefsitzende
Ängste oder auch Vorbehalte schürt und
das weiß die AKP natürlich und deswegen
hat man ja auch vor allem in den letzten
zwei Wochen vor der Wahl gezielt darauf
gesetzt diese Urängste würde ich sagen
einer mehrheitlichen nationalistischen
Bevölkerung zu schüren das heißt aber
letztendlich hatte die Opposition dann
gar keine Chance wenn man das sieht wenn
man die Medien übernachten über Nacht
sieht und sieht dass der Wahlkampf so
unfair gelaufen ist dann muss man sich
ja eigentlich wundern dass dass die
Opposition dann doch noch 44,5% bekommen
hat
naja letztendlich haben wir gesehen dass
die Opposition auch wirklich einen
großen Mobilisierungskraft an den Tag
gelegt hat und wenn wir über die
soziologischen Faktoren sprechen möchte
ich auch mal darüber sprechen wie
bemerkenswert eigentlich die Kundinnen
und Kurden die abgestimmt haben bei
dieser Wahl Verantwortung für eine
demokratische Gesamtheit übernommen
haben das sind die Gebiete in den killic
da wo du am stärksten vorne liegt bei
uns in die Arbeit hier wo wir betrachtet
haben mit rund 72 Prozent und das ist
beeindruckend wenn man die Geschichte
der kurdischen Bevölkerung und der
Oppositionspartei CHP kennt der Kita olu
angehört das ist glaube ich auch ein
ganz wesentlicher Faktor dass ich da
eine neue Solidarität unter Demokrat in
ergeben hat und das ist auch ein neues
Fundament aber diese Wahlen sind unfair
verlaufen und das sind natürlich
Strukturen die ist einer demokratischen
Opposition schwer machen zu mehr halten
zu kommen
sie wollten noch mal kommen auf den
Punkt weil sie sehr angesprochen
manipuliert worden sein könnte das ist
heute das ist das Meldung von heute
Nachmittag das ist noch sehr frisch
deswegen noch nicht kann man das noch
nicht abschließend beurteilen vor allem
weil es keine Überblick Darstellung gibt
aber seit heute
sind die Ergebnisse in einzelnen
Wahllokalen hat die Wahlkommission
veröffentlicht und das haben seither
Fragen Bürgerinnen und Bürger die als
Wahlhelfer oder auch als Bürger dass man
darf ja auch erstes Recht an der
Auszählung zu beobachten und auch dann
die Ergebnisprotokolle abzufotografieren
vergleichen die Ergebnisse die in diesem
in den Protokollen für die einzelne Urne
im Viertel sowieso in der Schule da und
da ohne Nummer so und so vergleicht das
kann man vergleichen diese Ergebnisse
mit den Ergebnissen der der amtlichen
Wahlkommission und es gibt wie gesagt
über das Ausmaß lässt sich im Moment
nicht sagen aber
in eine Orte sagten gerade
in der Kleinstadt bis Mail im Bezirk die
Wahlkommission notiert ungefähr 260 in
einer in einer Schule in einer
260 Stimmen für die Map für die Ultra
nationalistische mit Erdogan Verbündete
Map und für die kurdische Partei keine
einzige Stimme und wenn auch nur ein
bisschen die Soziologie der Türkei kennt
kann kann sie sieht das sofort dieses
Ergebnis ausgeschlossen
das könnte sein nur in dem Fall ist es
gibt es gibt die Protokolle auch diese
von dieser Schule und das Ergebnis was
für die Map eingetragen wurde war das
Ergebnis was die was die HDP die
aufgrund des Verbotsverfahrens dann
angetreten ist dort tatsächlich erzielt
hat es gibt wie gesagt über das Ausmaß
kann man im Moment noch nicht sagen aber
es gibt Hinweise und sowohl die alle
Oppositionsparteien auch die
säkularnationalistische gute Partei im
Block von von stahlrollo hat Anspruch
erhoben das das ist dann natürlich immer
nur lokal aber bis jetzt haben vier oder
fünf oder fünf
Provinzen wurden die Ergebnisse schon
dahin gehen korrigiert dass sich die
Mandatsverteilung geändert hat die
hydraupreise gerade die in Mersin ein
auf in dem rein der AKP ähm schon
gewählt wurde das wurde jetzt der guten
Partei zugeschlagen in Bartmann wiederum
der für die kurdische Partei wie gesagt
über das Ausmaß kann man noch nicht
sagen vor allem nicht ob das dazu
gereicht hat dass das am Ende zu
polieren aber ich glaube ich glaube dass
ich glaube selbst wenn sich der Eindruck
in der Opposition durchsetzt dass da
dass sie um den Wahlsieg betrogen wurde
dann glaube ich auch im Hinblick auf was
Katharina williger gerade gesagt auf die
Stichwahl dann könnte die psychologische
Überlegenheit die gerade im Moment
eindeutig auf Seiten von Erdogan ist das
könnte sich noch mal ändern und dann
könnten wir ein Effekt bekommen wie bei
der wiederholten Wahlliste Frau
Willinger wie würden sie es einschätzen
wenn diese Hinweise jetzt wirklich haben
sich wenn sich das bewahrheitet dass es
da Manipulation gegeben hat was würde
das für die Stichwahl heißen aus ihrer
Meinung
ja also die Vorwürfe die wiegen ja sehr
schwer ich habe jetzt gerade auch noch
mal die Nachrichtenlage aktuell gecheckt
da überschlagen sich auch die Ereignisse
es heißt ja jetzt mittlerweile von
Seiten der jeschel zur Party das ist die
Partei für die die HDP die Pro kurdische
Parteien ist mir angetragen eingetreten
ist dass sie Hinweise darauf haben dass
1000 centurnen falsch ins System des
hohen Wahlarzt eingetragen wurden das
ist natürlich eine massive Zahl und es
kommen wohl jetzt gerade in letzten
Minuten auch vermehrt Meldungen über
Unregelmäßigkeiten im ganzen Land rein
ich kann nicht sagen dass mich das
überrascht die Vermutung haben natürlich
gerade im journalistischen Umfeld sehr
viele Kollegen gehabt dass es
Unregelmäßigkeiten gab die
Wahlbeobachter haben es verhältnismäßig
dezent auch angedeutet ich kann nicht
sagen ob das etwas daran ändert wie der
hohe Wahlrat am Ende entscheidet denn
man muss ja auch dazu noch mal sagen
dass dieser hohe Wahlrad ja auch nicht
wirklich unabhängig ist die Mitglieder
dort sind von Erdogan also vom
Staatspräsident höchstpersönlich ernannt
und man weiß nicht ob das an der
Grundsatzentscheidung das ist in die
Stichwahl überhaupt gehen wird etwas
ändert Herr Lux was könnte denn könnten
sie denn nur die Wahl Beobachter könnten
sie denn da jetzt noch Einfluss nehmen
haben sie da irgendeine Handhabe dann
wir sind keine wahlaufpasser sondern
weil Beobachter das heißt wir beobachten
dokumentieren und versuchen dann am Ende
diese Dokumentation bestmöglich zu
teilen damit auch dann ein Politik
Entscheidung getroffen werden können
könnten was für uns aber sehr sehr
aufgefallen ist bei dieser
Wahlbeobachtung ist die massive
Intransparenz mit der der hohe wahlart
vorgeht und auch die wirklich mangelnde
Bereitschaft zu Kommunikation mit uns
als internationalen wahlbeobachterinnen
und Wahlbeobachtern aber auch mit den
Parteien die z.B Manipulationsvorwürfe
erheben und das ist natürlich etwas was
große Fragezeichen hinterlässt und auch
bei uns das Vertrauen in diesen hohen
Wahlrat wirklich auch ein Stück weit
beschädigt was würde das für die
Stichwahl jetzt heißen dann gehen sie
wieder hin und beobachten genau wie
beobachten und wir versuchen damit eine
Grundlage zu schaffen dass wir eben
Entscheidungen in Anschluss treffen
können das aber auch die Menschen im
Land wissen dass die internationale
Gemeinschaft dorthin guckt und das habe
ich auch ganz stark
hier auf der Straße gespielt mit den
Leuten gesprochen hat die gesagt haben
sie haben Angst vor dieser Wahl haben
die auch danach gesagt das ist gut dass
ihr hier seid und dass sie
internationale Präsenz zeigt und deshalb
ist es glaube ich auch so wichtig dass
wir diese Beobachtung fortsetzen am 28
Mai wie sehr können Sie sich vorstellen
als jemand der
Erdogan Anhänger ist dass das ist dort
Manipulation gibt also nach jedem Wagen
gibt er solche Vorwürfe oder
Widersprüche aber ich glaube nicht dass
es jetzt weil entscheidend ist ich muss
auch noch mal eben für den Medien was
man ist richtig dass die kommerzielle
Medien überwiegend von der Regelung
dominierte dabei es gibt auch soziale
Medien müssen
heute der auch 12 bis 15 Millionen
Zuschauer und wenn deine Sendung Mann
insofern würde ich jetzt die Wahl nicht
oder die Ergebnisse nicht nur über die
meine Situation und die werden Medien
macht und erklären sondern wir müssen
etwas tief greifen analysieren und etwas
Türkei hineingehen das wäre etwas zu
oberflächlich das nur über Medien und
der Waldbröl dazu zu erklären
gucken wir mal auf die türkische
Gemeinschaft hier in Deutschland dort
haben auch die meisten nämlich zwei
Drittel gut ungefähr für Erdogan
gestimmt der wie erklären Sie sich das
warum sind so viele der in Deutschland
lebende Türken Unterstützung da kann ich
nur hin letzte Stichwort aufgreifen und
genauso fortführen das hat was mit der
Soziologie zu tun das hat was mit den
mit der Soziologie der Einwanderer
religiös zu tun und zwar völlig
unabhängig davon wie einzelne
Wählerinnen und Wähler die hier wählen
es sind ja von den und etwa dreieinhalb
Millionen Türkei stimmigen Menschen in
Deutschland viele haben die
Staatsbürgerschaft gar nicht und von
denen die die wahlberechtigt sind das
sind etwa dass man jetzt anderthalb
Millionen diesmal 100.000 mehr als beim
letzten Mal geht etwas mehr es ist etwas
mehr als die Hälfte wählen gegangen also
von denen sind das
64%. ähm aber unabhängig von der
individuellen Motivation warum die Leute
sagen dass Sie Erdogan wählen was sich
abzeichnet ist das nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern in ehemaligen
Gastarbeiter starten
liegt zieht Erdogan Ergebnisse deutlich
über dem Schnitt in der Türkei in
Österreich in Belgien in Holland in in
Frankreich
übrigens auch die HDP die Kurden das
sind die zweite ist die zweite Partei
die in den Gastarbeiter starten immer
deutlich über die Ergebnisse der Türkei
Lack aber in Großbritannien zum Beispiel
haben wir also den setze ich die
türkische Community zusammen aus sehr
viel Leuten die als politische
Flüchtlinge nach dem militärbutsch 80
und den 90er Jahren kam sehr viele
Kurden darunter aber auch sehr viele gut
ausgebildete ähm
Einwanderer da hat die hat kann sein
oder 80% erzielt genauso in den USA wo
die türkische Community eine völlig
andere zusammengesetzt hat also die in
einem Satz in einem Satz im Großen und
Ganzen die Milieus aus denen die
Einwanderer Communitys in den jeweiligen
Ländern in der ersten oder sich
zusammensetzt so wie diese Milieus
mehrheitlich abstimmt spiegelt sich das
in den Ergebnissen hier wieder gibt
keinen Einfluss zum Beispiel der eine
UID der Union liberaler Entschuldigung
der Uni und internationaler Demokraten
dessen Vizepräsident sie haben sich da
ja zurückgezogen also wie stark ist denn
dieser Einfluss dieser Organisation
auf Englisch die machen eigentlich ein
sehr logistische Wahlkampf also die
Propaganda dürfen nicht über die sondern
über die Medien über soziale Medien über
die Türkei waren für die meisten
türkische bürgerliche Leben die schauen
sich auch die türkischen Medien insofern
man erlebt ja auch die ganzen
wirtschaftliche Probleme hier in der im
Ausland nicht sondern man sieht nur die
Vorzeigeprojekte im Fleisch zurück zum
Projekt der Rüstungsprojekte und ist ja
jemand der seine Anhänger auch eine
gewisse
stolz gibt und das ich will alles seine
wichtige Rolle dass man Erdogan
ID wird vom deutschen Verfassungsschutz
beobachtet ja aber die ist ja bis jetzt
nichts kriminelles gemacht
aber das ist ja keine Widerspruch und
der Türkei wählen die Leute ja auch
nicht einfach so diese wählen sondern es
ist natürlich auch
so wie das so wie das in der Türkei
läuft spiegelt sich Katharina wird
glaube ich spiegelt sich das dann auch
hier wieder natürlich haben die Einfluss
aber wie gesagt das ist
in der Türkei nicht anders damit mit
diesem Argumenten können wir den Ball
der Vorfall er soll nicht allein wir
müssen etwas tiefgreifender gehen wie
ich ihm gesagt habe dort für mich mit
einer Rolle das spielt auch da ich bin
auch andere Faktoren eine Rolle ich bin
der Meinung das habe ich auch in den
letzten Ländern gehört die Türkei ist
ein Land der dich von aus innere Dynamik
kennen nicht moderieren kann
Perspektive gehabt in der Türkei so Ende
der 90er bis Ende des Endes 2010 dann
gab es eine Reformprozess in der Türkei
dann Leuchte oder Holz gut aber nachdem
wie der op-perspektive
in der Türkei wieder angefangen dann
verschiedene etliche Gruppen das sind
verschiedene Gruppen und die politische
Kampf läuft nicht über den guten
werkstattpolitik oder schlechte Politik
sondern über etliche Probleme über
konventionelle Probleme und dann gibt es
in der Türkei auch 6 Millionen zu
Einwanderer nicht nur aus Syrien sondern
auch auf keinen Fall egal und viele
anderen Ländern und das hat auch dazu
geführt dass in diesem bei diesem Ball
25% der Wille für gestimmt haben also
jeden Tag
also wir müssen etwas grundgründlich an
die Probleme reingehen alles andere wäre
für mich auch ein bisschen oberflächlich
also man muss sich jetzt
diese Zuwanderungspolitik diese
Einwanderung jetzt gerade wenn man diese
Nationalität sehen und nur andere
Probleme Frau Willinger was würden Sie
denn sagen nach nach ihrer Analyse was
ist so der der Hauptgrund wodurch dann
doch so viele Menschen sagen erdogan ist
der richtige Präsident für uns obwohl es
eine starke Inflation geht obwohl es der
Wirtschaft so schlecht gibt obwohl es
das Erdbeben gab wo ja alle gesagt haben
die das die Katastrophenhilfe war nicht
gut genug die die Kritik an der Bauweise
all das gab es ja warum ist das nicht
als Argument genug
naja also auf dem Papier gab es ja die
Einbußen auch jetzt wo wir noch nicht
wissen eben sind die endgültigen Zahlen
also die gab's schon auch ich bin
überrascht wenn ich die Zahlen sehe die
wir im den Erdbeben Gebieten sehen wenn
sie dann stimmen also ich spreche jetzt
immer im Konjunktiv in diesem Fall denn
ich habe damit gerechnet dass es dann
wesentlich größeren Stimmverlust gibt
ich glaube die Gründe die haben wir ja
auch schon mehrmals aufgezählt das ist
dann schon so eben dass sie das die
Regierungspartei der Staatspräsident
einfach mit der ganzen Propaganda die
ihr dann am Ende ja auch über so viele
Kanäle schicken konnten viele Wähler
noch mal dazu bewogen hat ihm die Stimme
zu geben es wird ja auch immer die Angst
geschürt das Land könnte ins Chaos
stürzen also damit wird ja auch ganz
geschickt gespielt aber einen wichtigen
Punkt den wir vielleicht auch noch mal
ansprechen sollten ist die Selbstkritik
innerhalb der Opposition die ist nicht
unbedingt sehr groß also man kann sich
ja auch Fragen selbstkritisch warum hat
diese Opposition trotzdem
verheerenden Wirtschaftslage trotz
dieses Erdbebens und den krassen Folgen
ich meine da sind mehr als 50.000
Menschen umgekommen warum hat es die
Opposition und auch schon vor dem
Erdbeben nicht geschafft mehr Menschen
auf ihre Seite zu ziehen also da hat die
Opposition ja auch ganz klar verpasst
den Menschen im Land ein Angebot zu
machen und es wurde natürlich daran dass
er der falsche Kandidat
das kann ich nicht sagen ob es der
falsche Kandidat war es gibt sehr viele
Argumente für ihn sicher und genauso
viele gibt es auch gegen ihn ja es gibt
viele die sagen immer Mono das ist der
Bürgermeister hier in Istanbul von der
CHP der Partei von Kultus Derulo wäre
der bessere Kandidat gewesen es gibt
genauso viele die sagen nie das wäre
nicht gut gewesen also vielleicht liegt
am Ende auch nicht am Kandidaten sondern
es liegt auch an alten Strukturen
innerhalb der Parteien innerhalb der
Bevölkerung ist herrscht einfach leider
in der Bevölkerung nach wie vor ein
extremes Schwarz Weiß denken das hat die
Regierung in den letzten Jahren auch
nach wie vor also auch immer wieder
verschärft in den Ängste geschürt worden
sind aber es gibt einfach sehr viele
Menschen innerhalb dieser Bevölkerung
die sagen ich kann die CHP ich kann
immer nicht wählen diese Partei steht
gegen so vieles was mir wichtig ist das
ist tief verwurzelt immer noch bei
vielen und mit dieser Angst eben mit
diesem Vorteil spielt natürlich die
Regierungspartei auch ganz geschickt
aber die Emotion hat er auch in in
vielerlei Hinsicht nicht besonders viel
entgegengesetzt Herr Lux was würden Sie
denn sagen wenn man auf die Menschen
hier in Deutschland schaut und auch über
auf die Rolle der Türkei auch für das
deutsche türkische Verhältnis sie sind
Vorsitzender der deutsch-türkischen
Parlamentariergruppe hätte es auch eine
Möglichkeit gegeben von Deutschland aus
Einfluss zu nehmen macht das ja
offiziell nicht aber gab es Einfluss zu
nehmen auf diese Wahl den die Opposition
zu stärken also die Rolle Deutschlands
ist ja nicht anderen Ländern zu erklären
was dort gewählt werden soll aber
natürlich finde ich das auch als
deutscher Politiker und als
Bundestagsabgeordneter aus dem
Ruhrgebiet meinen Wahlkreis liegt mein
Buch immer bei Kreis liegt im Bezirk das
generalkonsultation Essen also das
generalkons also die müssen höchsten
Stimmenanzahl für Erdogans Deutschland
besorgniserregend das ist so eine hohe
Zustimmung gibt weil diese
Zustimmungsrate ja sich auch mit dem
widerspricht was doch eigentlich im
Interesse von Ernährung und Kooperation
liegt also wenn man eine Türkei will die
einen engen Draht nach Europa sucht und
einen engen Draht nach Deutschland sucht
dann ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so
ratsam ein Präsidenten zu wählen der
diese Türkei weg von Europa und weg von
Deutschland führen möchte wenn man zum
Beispiel Visafreiheit erreichen möchte
dann braucht es eine Ernährung der
Türkei an Deutschland die
deutsch-türkischen Beziehungen sind
auf einem sehr sehr tiefen Punkt auch
wegen der wirklich fürchterlichen
Menschenrechtslage in der Türkei
angekommen und das Ende dieses
Tiefpunkts wird nicht in Sicht sein wenn
Erdogan an der Macht bleibt und das ist
natürlich ein Problem und das ist doch
gerade auch für die Menschen die ein
deutsch-türkischen Bezug haben ein
Problem bedeuten allerdings und
sozusagen wenn sie in ihrem Wahlkreis
unterwegs sind also das meint ihr
natürlich muss die deutsche Politik da
nicht Ratschläge erteilen aber gibt es
ein Punkte wo sie wenn Menschen ins
Gespräch kommen und ja da auch eine
Überzeugungsarbeit leisten können
naja was wird schon erleben ist glaube
ich das bestimmte Stadtteile gibt
insbesondere im Ruhrgebiet die wirklich
abgehängt sind in den viele Menschen
leben die schlechte Bedingungen
vorfinden werden mal Nordrhein-Westfalen
die Situation dass die Allianz
Deutschland Demokraten angetreten ist
ein deutscher AKP Ableger und dann
hatten wir Landtagswahlen haben gesehen
dass dieser AKP Ableger gerade in den
Stadtteil im Ruhrgebiet stark ist wo
auch die AFD stark ist ja das heißt wir
haben eigentlich zwei rechtsextreme
Ansätze erlebt die sich aneinander
wirklich
regelrecht exkopieren wenn man zum
Beispiel nach Gelsenkirchen Ückendorf wo
ich geboren wurde schaut und das ist
eine große Herausforderung wenn ich mit
Leuten in meinem wahlkreissäge habe ich
aber auch in meiner Bürgersprechstunde
Leute die wütend sind das ist immer noch
keine Visa Freiheit gibt was auch an
Erdogan liegt aber die nicht vielen
können wenn ich mit Leuten in meinem
Wahlkreis spreche dann denke ich auch in
den kurdischen Familienvater aus Bochum
den ich meinem ist dann wohler
Generalkonsulat besucht habe als er
seine Ausreise Sperre aus politischen
Gründen in der Türkei hat und der auch
nicht wählen und das sind auch alles
Menschen die zu deutsch-türkischen
Lebensrealität dazugehören die oftmals
nicht wählen dürfen und die wir auch
nicht vergessen sollten in dieser
Debatte also erstmal muss ich dekorieren
man kann Leute die Abfahrt werden nicht
mit dem AFD wieder vergleichen das ist
auch soziologischen möchte das gerne
vielleicht bestätigen und die abbreite
ist keine rechtsextreme-partei die ist
eine Konsole die Partei der zum Teil
auch an die bürgerliche Schicht ja es
gibt auch unterschiedlich etwas
natürlich sind aber man kann die ab
heute nicht definitiv nicht mit der AFD
vergleichen ich glaube ich glaube die
von heute nicht die gegründete akape ich
glaube die AKP von heute ist gleich viel
mehr eine kriminellenvereinigung als
einer Partei mit verschiedenen strömen
ich wohne sind was anderes aber die
Partei Struktur ist heute die hatte
diese den politischen Islam die
Konservativen liberale es gab sogar
ehemalige linke der der
grüne Kulturminister das ist heute die
Parteistruktur eine andere aber ich
wollte noch eine Sache zu hören Essen
erwähnt haben das andere Essen ist immer
das Generalkonsulat wo die Erdogan und
akafé in Deutschland wie die besten
Ergebnisse erzielt Berlin ist das ist
das schlechteste da liegen 20% Punkte
dazwischen ich finde auch das eine Indiz
dafür dass für das Wahlverhalten der
deutschen ehe die Milieu und
identitätszugehörigkeiten wichtige
ausschlaggebender sind als Erfahrung die
man in in Deutschland sehr viele Leute
gibt die nach dem militärproteine Türkei
ist die Youtuber in der Türkei und
darauf macht ja wenn sie darauf ein paar
Mal auch angesprochen ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich etwas was er dann in den
letzten Jahren vor allem ungefähr
vielleicht in den letzten 10 Jahren
gemacht letzten 10 Jahren gemacht hat
Wahlkämpfe zu Volksabstimmung um zu
funktionieren zu Volkszählung wurde in
den Leute nach Identität also das ist
Identitätspolitik und Leute Stimmen nach
Identität Zugehörigkeiten ab und offen
nach den jetzigen Ergebnissen nach dem
jetzigen Ergebnissen die man jetzt wie
gesagt aus besagten Gründen mit gewissen
Vorsicht auch betrachten muss haben
andere politische Themen wie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Grundrechte
wirtschaftswirtschaftliche Situation
Verstrickung von zwischen Staat und
Mafia und und und nicht so eine Rolle
gespielt das einzige politische Thema
neben identitäts- und Milieu
Zugehörigkeiten ist wie Herr gewinnen
sagte das einzige politische Thema was
eine Rolle spielt ist das Thema
Flüchtlinge und ein letztes zu Frau
Willinger
ich glaube selbst wenn diese Ergebnisse
manipuliert sein sollten ist völlig klar
die erdogan hat diese war nicht gewonnen
aber die Opposition hat sie auch nicht
gewonnen weil in einem Land wieder
Türkei mit einer trotz allem so gut
aufgestellten
Opposition eine Zivilgesellschaft mit 70
Jahren Demokratie erfahren das war ja
zum Jahrestag der ersten der ersten dann
wirklich frei war beim ersten Mal 46
wurde manipuliert systematisch zu diesem
Bundestag angesetzt in so einem Land
kann man nicht selbst wenn manipuliert
sein sollte kann man nicht fünf oder
zehn oder 15 Prozentpunkte ein
Wahlergebnis fälschen das ist
ausgeschlossen also wenn überhaupt dann
reden wir um die entscheidenden
Prozentpunkte aber das ist überhaupt so
weit gekommen ist das ist natürlich
etwas das ist ein schlechtes Abschneiden
der Opposition
hätte vielleicht wäre vielleicht ein
geeigneter gewesen
er ist
in einem
völlig absurden Verfahren zu einer
Haftstrafe verurteilt worden er hat und
hat die justizunter seine Kontrolle und
die Überlegung war dass man nach
Abschluss des nominierungsverfahrens
hätte er hätte immer Mode hätte einfach
das Berufungsgericht das Urteil
bestätigen können und er wäre mit
Politik verboten belegt und hätte nicht
kandidieren können man könnte jetzt die
Frage stellen ob die Opposition das
hätte riskieren müssen um eine
Geschichte um eine Leidensgeschichte zu
schaffen wie Erdogan ja auch hatte das
ist eine Frage aber auch noch
platzierten kann Kandidaten ihnen Ohren
der hat ja bislang gar keine
Wahlempfehlung abgegeben Frau Willinger
das ist ja ultra nationalistisches
Wahlbündnisses spielt das überhaupt noch
eine Rolle was er jetzt dann für eine
Wahlempfehlung abgibt für die Menschen
die auf ihn gestimmt gegeben haben
also da gibt es vermutlich verschiedene
Meinungen meine Meinung ist dass es
nicht der Königsmacher sein wird wir
oftmals gerade in den westlichen Medien
gerade deklariert wird denn zum einen
sie uns angesprochen er hat noch keine
Wahlempfehlung abgegeben die Tendenz ist
aber eher dahin gehen dass er sich
entweder zurückhält oder das Erdogan
Lager unterstützt seine Wähler würde ich
sagen stehen auch Erdogan näher als
coolster Rollo aber selbst wenn sich
Sinan Ohren warum auch immer auf die
Seite von schlagen sollte weil er
beispielsweise in den guten Posten
versprochen bekommt dann kann man nicht
davon ausgehen dass diese 5,3 waren es
glaube ich am Ende Prozent seiner Wähler
allesamt zur Opposition gehen würden und
ähm den hat es ja gerade angesprochen es
geht hier um entscheidende ein zwei drei
vier Prozentpunkte diese Regierung wird
nicht verlieren weil sie nicht verlieren
kann denn wenn sie verliert dann haben
sie wirklich ja ich wiederhole alles
verloren im wahrsten Sinne und daran
muss man diese Wahl auch messen das muss
man betonen und die Parlamentswahl hat
die auch gewonnen das wäre ja dann auch
noch eine Frage da gab es ja die
absolute Mehrheit wie das überhaupt
gehen könnte alleine hat eben genau und
das ist glaube ich das entscheidende
wenn wir die über die AKP heute auch
reden die akapi hat mich einfach alleine
diese Parlamentswahl gewonnen als EVP
assoziierte Partei sondern sie ist ja
übrigens auch nicht mehr mit der evpin
Verbindung sondern jetzt in einem Block
gewonnen da ist die MHP dabei die den
grauen Wölfen da steht größte
rechtsextreme Organisation in
Deutschland Verfassungsschutzbericht da
ist die kurdische historler mit der
hühnerpartie beispielsweise paar Zeit da
ist die Riva Party dabei und das ist
natürlich etwas was wahnsinnig
besorgniserregend ist das Erdogan als
Antwort auf ein sehr breites
demokratisches Bündnis das kilage da
ohne geformt hat und ich finde dafür
kann man ihm auch wirklich Respekt
sollen ein Bündnis von Meral actiona aus
dem starken nationalistischen Lager ist
trainingsradikante Partei zu formulieren
dagegen hat Erdogan ein Bündnis mit sehr
Besorgnis Regen erregenden Partnern
gesetzt und das ist etwas was wirklich
auch Angst macht dass das funktioniert
die AKP hat es immer noch 7% Punkte
verloren in absoluten Zahlen ist das
sogar noch dramatische die hat
anderthalb Millionen Stimmen weniger
bekommen als beim letzten Mal obwohl
diesmal 4 Millionen Menschen mehr
wahlberechtigt waren und der Punkt war
nur wieder unter dem Vorzeichen dass
diese Ergebnisse so korrekt sind dass
Sie dass die akapi innerhalb dieses
Bündnisses Wähler verloren hat das Leute
für andere Parteien gestimmt haben aber
dann für Erdogan und das ist aber auch
eine Frage die sich auch bei einer
Stichwahl zählt wird werden sie die
Stimmen von Leuten bekommen die die bei
der Parteien weil für eine andere Partei
gestimmt haben und dann quasi im
Vorübergehen dann auch
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl auch für
Erdogan das gilt die die für dieselbe
Frage stellt sich auch das gilt vor
allem für die kurdischen Gebiete wo er
seine besten Ergebnisse erzielt hat was
für die Stichwahl
heißt wenn sie unter ganz korrekten
Bedingungen verläuft kann das bedeuten
dass es ein ähnliches Ergebnis wieder
kommt das kann bedeuten dass Erdogan
aber auch wenn er wenn du diese Wähler
nicht nur mobilisieren kann das dann
deutlich besseres Ergebnis erzielt und
auch wenn das der unwahrscheinlichste
Fall ist aber ganz ausschließen finde
ich allein bei der genauen Betrachtung
der Ergebnisse und der bei dem Vergleich
zwischen dem Parlaments zwischen den
parteienergebnisse und der
Präsidentschaftswahl kann man es glaube
ich auch nicht ganz ausschließen dass
Christen
beendet auch wenn das auch wenn das der
unterschiedlichste der dran ist
nicht mehr so viel Zeit ich würde immer
gerne auf die Rolle auch der EU schauen
auf die Rolle der Türkei eben in der in
der Außenpolitik auch das
flüchtlingsabkommen haben sie
angesprochen da stand ja auch
für eine schärfere
migrationspolitiker looks wenn man jetzt
noch mal schaut wie das Verhältnis EU
und Türkei ist was würde sich verändern
oder was wie gibt es einen Punkt wo man
sagen muss welche Lehren müsste dann der
Westen daraus ziehen wenn für die
nächsten Jahre wenn Erdogan weiter
Präsident bleibt also das Verhältnisse
Türkei ist ja nicht davon abhängig was
das Parteibuch des Staatspräsidenten ist
sondern es Verhältnis EU Türkei ist
davon abhängig wie eine Situation ist
wie ein Verhältnis miteinander ist und
dass das kilica olu davor geschlagen hat
das geht natürlich stark in die Richtung
die man sich in Europa erhofft nämlich
zum Beispiel der ist dann wo Konvention
zum Schutz von Frauen wieder dabei zu
treten auch die eu-beitrittsverhandlung
wieder aufzunehmen die
rechtsstaatsprinzipien umzusetzen vor
allem die Mutter des Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte umsetzen
wir sprechen diesen Tagen kaum darüber
dass was man Kavala und relativ immer
noch zu Unrecht im Gefängnis sitzen
obwohl der europäische für
Menschenrechte die in die Türkei
übrigens schon länger unterliegt als
Deutschland schon ganz lange die
Freilassung dieser beiden Personen
angeordnet hat und das ist massiver
Ballast für das Verhältnis zwischen
Europa und der Türkei und natürlich ist
es so dass Europa das muss man
selbstkritisch eingestiegen den
vergangenen Jahren die Türkei eher so
ein bisschen als handelsmasse zum
outsourcen eine eigene Probleme
verstanden hat und das ist natürlich ein
Problem und deshalb glaube ich wir
brauchen eine solidarische Lösung der
Flüchtlingsfrage mit der Türkei und
innerhalb Europas und müssen und müssen
und müssen viel viel stärker in Europa
die Menschenrechtspolitik oben auf die
Agenda gegenüber der Türkei setzen und
in Europa ist da derzeit eher die
Stimmung dass das als Hobby der
deutschen betrachtet wird und das glaube
ich nicht die hinreichende Antwort und
dann Frau Willinger noch mal dazu also
ich glaube
Türkei Beziehung dann sehr
oberflächliche Analyse und zwar deshalb
die Sachen sind ja in der Türkei deshalb
zum Teil aus dem Boden gefallen weil die
Türkei einfach Perspektive verloren hat
also wenn man ich bin der Meinung man
muss der Türkei wenn man die Beziehung
verbessern will eine Angebot machen das
muss nicht unbedingt eine volles
Mitgliedschaft sein das kann eine
Premiere Partnerschaft sein und da kann
man damit anfangen dass man z.B das
solunium Modellen wird oder dass man z.B
damit wie die eben gesagt haben der
diese Freiheit gibt
72 Punkte die türkische Parlament
umsetzen müssen an sie wundervoll
umgesetzt es geht nur um einiges an die
Terror gesetzt das hat man zum anders
genommen und mit dem Freund nicht
gewinnen ich glaube das machbar aber man
muss eine ehrliche eigene Mutter der
Türkei machen auch wenn Eltern gewinnen
sollte man muss natürlich keine ehrliche
Antwort machen damit die Beziehung nicht
vergessen das wird auch positiv auf
wenn man eine gute Angebote macht
also spielt das überhaupt eine Rolle im
Wahlkampf also die Frage der die die
Perspektive für in der EU mieser
Freiheit all diese Sachen spielte das
eine Rolle
und wird das jetzt die nächsten Tage
vielleicht noch mal eine wichtige Rolle
spielen
naja ich denke es geht jetzt in den in
den nächsten Tagen vor allen Dingen um
innenpolitische Aspekte vor allen Dingen
hat heute schon angekündigt auch dass
man sich jetzt vermehrt auch noch mal um
die junge Wählerschaft kümmern will es
hat natürlich eine Rolle gespielt eben
der Oppositionsführer hat auch immer
wieder betont dass man mit der EU in
neugespräche gehen möchte dass es mieser
freiheit ist ein großes Thema ich glaube
aber um das auch noch mal abzuschließen
nicht dass das Verhältnis Türkei
Deutschland nicht am Parteibuch des
Staatspräsidenten hängt sondern ich
glaube dass die Person Erdogan einen
großen Einfluss darauf hat wie das
Verhältnis Deutschland Türkei aber eben
auch EU Türkei ist und dass das
natürlich unter einem anderen
Präsidenten noch mal völlig neue
Voraussetzungen haben könnte denn die
Annahme dass das deutsche Verhältnis zur
Türkei unabhängig davon funktioniert die
halte ich in dem Fall für naiv wir leben
in einem bzw ich lebe mein leben ja in
Deutschland ich lebe wir berichten aus
einem Land das zunehmend autokratischer
wird das muss ich so feststellen eben
die Unabhängigkeit der Justiz ist nicht
mehr da und das würde so ist das
Versprechen der Opposition sich unter
jemanden wie kurz da Rollo ändern ich
glaube nicht dass die Türkei ein
musterstaat an Demokratie werden würde
das war sie unter europäischen
Voraussetzungen vorher sicherlich auch
nicht hier herrschen noch mal andere
Spielregeln aber ich denke schon dass
ich dann dann auch in den Beziehungen
zur EU und zu Deutschland einiges ändern
konnte
man sich hier auf der anderen Seite also
bei der Ablehnung bei der Abweisung der
Türkei von der von von von Europa das
spielte das war Anfang des das war eine
große Versprechen mit den Erdogan
angetreten ist aber das war nicht nur
Erdung das hat quasi gesamte türkische
Gesellschaft hat um die Jahrtausendwende
aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen haben
alle wollten alle gelöst in die EU Erde
und hat das als stärkste in die Hand
genommen und seinem ersten Wahlkampf
2002 und es war es war Angela Merkel in
Deutschland und Nicolas sarkozi in
Frankreich die irgendwann den Türken
klar gemacht haben ihr kommt hier nicht
rein weil wir euch nicht rein wollen
unabhängig wie Wirtschaft euren
Rechtsstand und so weiter auf Vordermann
bringt aber ich würde ich würde gerne
zum Abschluss würde gern ein Punkt noch
sagen zu Erdogan und der türkischen
rechten und der Frage um den Punkt zur
wahlmodulation zu machen in der Türkei
hatte die Linke sowohl die staatliche
als auch die außerparlamentarische immer
so eine jakobinische Tradition auf der
anderen Seite waren das die
Konservativen die Konservativen admines
der 50 gewählt wurde auf dem sich die
Mitte rechts Parteien die Erde und Beruf
haben immer getragen von wähle von der
von von Willen des Volkes erdogan hat
immer gesagt ich bin kein Diktator ich
wurde gewählt deswegen er versuchten
wird das reichen zu atmen mit allen
Tricks an der Macht zu bleiben aber wenn
er abgewählt wird wird Erdogan sich eine
ab eine wird er auch gehen weil dafür
die demokratischen Tradition der Türkei
bei allen Mengen immer noch stark genug
sind gerade auf Seiten auch das
politischen Islams aus dem herkommt wie
diese die Stichwahl am 28 ausgeht ich
Frage haben sie eine Prognose ja also
ich glaube so 52 53% für Erdogan
ich habe keine Prognose aber ich habe
eine Hoffnung dass es einen Präsidenten
geben wird der wieder die Annäherung an
Europa sucht und dafür steht der Kitsch
da oben Frau Wellinger sagen
ich wage keine Prognose mehr in der
Türkei kann wirklich in wenigen Stunden
vieles passieren ich hoffe nur für für
die Bevölkerung hier im Land das alles
friedlich bleibt inshallah nur das Beste
okay gut dann sind wir gespannt wir sind
von Phoenix am 28 auf jeden Fall für Sie
da und dann in der Woche danach in der
Phönix Runde werden wir das dann auch
analysieren natürlich jetzt geht's
weiter mit der Tag und Thomas Bart und
morgen schauen wir in der Phönix Runde
noch mal auf die Entwicklungen im
Ukraine kriegt bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]